expect referring to determinants their
nature it's a really really important
phrase you'll see it come up again and
again and again what it means is your
every we're talking about stationary
points and turning points yesterday
right so we want to work out what kind
of stationary point is this which way
does it turn or does it do something
else as you look that later so how do we
find this how do you determine whether
something say a maximum or a minimum
what do we do yeah we want to check what
happens to the derivative on either side
okay so here's what we're gonna do we
want to draw a table for ourselves
weight checking two stationary points
right so before when we were checking
one stationary point we said look at
some X values look at the derivative at
those X values and I said look kick your
stationary point right and then a pick
pick a point on either side of okay so -
103 what is that it's minus one over one
point seven which must be zero point on
me like decimal what is it point five
night okay great now the reason why I
want this decimal is because I need to
pick a point to the left and to the
right okay so what's a nice easy point
to the length of this I could pick now
this is negative sorry
so to the left I could pick minus 1/2 or
I could pick minus 1 that would do right
I'm gonna go with minus 1 because I
don't like fractions a little bit it's
racist what you don't like different
races so what is it when you doing crash
with fascist numbers anyway anyway okay
- one is to the left
what supping to the right zeros to the
right now you've got to be careful here
- remember I mentioned is sort of very
quickly yesterday and you can't go too
far away
okay like for example if I put in ten or
a hundred I would come up with problems
and here is why this is one of
stationary words and this is what I
would have as a table if I was just
testing
this station report but of course I've
got another station point that I'm
testing right the next one over okay
so therefore I should actually make this
table a bit longer this makes sense
okay and I should have one on Route
three which is the next station in point
there and this is approximately we just
said point five eight
okay so for instance if I said well
there's minus one there's my station
point if I want to send one here I would
have gone past this stationary point
right so something different is gonna
happen with the derivative which is
going to give me a different result so
you may even like to mention this is a
station point this is station to point
and these are the in between modes so
let's pick one on the end that'll be
most of it okay
now let's fill in these plots here
because you already know them right and
these locations the derivative is equal
to zero because that's what we just
that's how we found those values okay so
now you need to take these and pop them
into your derivative equation okay three
x squared minus 1 3 x squared minus 1 so
3 times minus 1 squared is just 3 so 3
minus 1 is at 0 3 times 0 squared minus
1 is 0 minus 1 ok and again this is the
great thing about this is why we spent
so long looking at all functions right
because I picked a point absurd yeah
right this is actually not an odd
function this is an even function right
3 x squared minus 1 the derivative is
even and so what derivative you
expecting over here exactly the same
right because I picked them on opposite
sides right so this is your f of X and
this is your f of minus X ok so through
tricks this is why we spent so long at
early this year so now you've got your
numbers you draw a little directional
waves indicate well what do these
numbers mean so a positive gradient
means it's increasing okay and then this
one is horizontal cos 0 okay and then
this one is negative right so it's
decreasing
another stationary point and you'll get
the idea okay and of course this
substring of lines right which is really
just us interpreting the sign of the
derivative it does kind of look like
what you'd expect this to be which we're
going to graph in a second okay so why
don't draw this table at all why do I do
this for i wanted to determine nature
determine which one's max which one's a
min so I would say therefore this one
here the first one is a maximum soliton
is a max turning point at and then I
provide the coordinate okay and of
course the r1 is a minimum
all right that's potty okay